ah boy I didn't think we'd get past
security out there yeah I know now we
just have to get past all our
insecurities up here okay hello
I'm Meryl Street and I'm Lily Tomlin and
and tonight we are pleased to honor a
man
we're honoring a man man who we honor
that's what men who didn't that's my
reading my line a man who didn't play by
the rules yeah that's what I said who
didn't play by the rules or stick to the
script a script I am you know I'm
agreeing with you I'm agreeing with you
I'm just saying that Robert Altman
didn't stick to the script he colors
outside the line and he wants actors to
do the same thing Yeah right
he doesn't want to act no and I'm
grateful for that he he wants the kind
of spontaneity that can only come from
not knowing what the hell you're doing
like like now it like now right yes he
just starts to film and we watch the
dailies and and it's some magical
pointer starts to wake up to him to
itself yeah and you see and you you say
oh I see I see something's happening
yeah but usually you know what it is no
but but but Altman does because
otherwise it wouldn't be happening
and his moviemaking style just does seem
to enhance our capacity to take in more
sounds and more images than we ever knew
we had the process the ability to
process you know because the movies it
seemed to have a different metabolism
than other movie well he's always been
ahead of the curve he just he'd hips
just kind of and he's able to capture
the curve 10 times Aaron with floating
cameras extended zooms incredibly
living almost like they came from a
parallel universe and I'm up to some
movie goers it seems as if the popcorn
they'd just been munching had suddenly
turned into peyote buttons oh it's just
wow
I wouldn't know so no I mean just know
you're taking you yes mash McCabe and
mrs. Miller Kansas City Nashville Long
Goodbye thieves like us shortcuts
Gosford Park California split the player
come back to the five-and-dime Jimmy
Dean Jimmy Dean so many so many others
and television he does plays he does
operas it's a over you know did I say
Nashville yes it bears it bears
repeating I must say you're you're
worried now that I'm got a laugh that
you didn't get oh I can see you know I
can feel it I can feel it man over the
years he has fired our neurons opened
our eyes and bloodied a few noses well
yes
even his own he's a satirist he's a sage
he's examined the my new particulars of
human behavior and he's doing it right
now and he's dying for us and we are all
richer for it but if sometimes you don't
understand the endings and even if even
if you don't understand the overlapping
dialogue we leave his movies knowing a
life I've been many things at one at
once Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
thanks very much
I got a lot to say they've got a clock
on me I want to thank the everybody for
this the Academy I was really honored
and moved to accept this award when the
news first came to me about it I was
caught kind of off-guard I always
thought this type of award met that it
was over and then it dawned on me that
I'm was busy in rehearsals in on a play
and I'm doing in London right now it
opened last night Arthur Miller's last
play resurrection blues I was doing an
interview for my new film that I just
finished Prairie Home Companion which
would come out in the summer and I
realized that it's not over of course I
was happy and thrilled and thrilled to
accept this award and I look at it as a
nod to all of my films because to me I
just made one long film and I know some
of you have liked some of the sections
and others you anyway it's all right and
I want to thank all of the people that
have worked on all of my pictures so so
hard and the brilliant actors the
amazing cruise and I can't name them all
so I'm going to name a doctor that's
taken care of me Jody Kaplan so she
represents everybody
and who supported me and made it
possible I've always said that making a
film is like making a sandcastle at the
beach you invite your friends and you
get them down there and you say you
build this beautiful structure and
several of you and then you sit back
when watch the tide come in have a drink
watch the tide come in and the ocean
just takes it away and that sandcastle
remains in your mind now I've built
about 40 of them and I'm I never tire of
it
no other filmmaker has gotten a better
shape than I have I'm very fortunate in
my career I've never had a director film
I didn't choose our develop I love the
filmmaking it has given me an entree to
the world and the human condition and
for that I'm forever grateful finally
I'd like to thank thank my family but
you're all right there all of them
almost for their love and support and
through the years and most importantly I
want to thank and applaud my wife
Katherine Reed Altman without whom I
wouldn't be here today I love you Chris
thank you oh one more thing I'm here I
think under kind of false pretenses and
I I think I have to get become straight
with you
ten years ago 11 years ago I had a heart
transplant a total heart transplant I
got the heart of it I think a young
woman who is about in her late 30s and
so by that kind of calculation you may
be giving me this award too early
because I think I got about 40 years
left on it and I am tender usual
you